make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and for this installment of our
beyond omega levels series we're going
to get somewhat
abstract as we turn our attention to one
of the most powerful forces in dc
comics and also one that you guys have
been requesting all the time
the great evil beast now the great evil
beast first appeared in swamp thing
number 50 in 1986 which was part of alan
moore's celebrated and
character-defining run
on the series now the great evil beast
introduction into the dc universe was
the culmination of a storyline known as
american gothic which began in swamp
thing number 37 which coincidentally
marked the first
appearance of jon constantine and so
when constantine shows up we find out
that he's meeting with a variety of his
associates each of which
are describing the inevitable return of
some unknown entity
with each of them describing it in a
different way a woman named judith
claims that there's nothing supernatural
about the entity that is merely a
massive extragalactic energy field that
was sucked into a black hole eight
billion years ago a man named benjamin
cox describes it as cthulhu the elder
god featured in the work of h.p
lovecraft and a nun named sister
anne-marie
describes it as being satan from
judeo-christianity and so they also
speak of a group of south americans that
are working to bring about the return
of this entity but not much information
is provided about who they are at this
point and so constantine then travels to
louisiana where swamp thing is being
regrown from the destruction of his body
by a villain known as nuke face
constantine convinces swan thing to meet
him in rosewood illinois when he's
finished growing and in return
constantine will reveal the swamp thing
things about himself that he could never
learn on his own
meanwhile judith ben and sister
anne-marie are all overtaken by some
evil force so intense that judith throws
herself out of a window to escape it
swamp thing then shows up in illinois to
help constantine and it turns out that
he needed to eradicate some vampires
that have been living underwater in
rosewood which of course he does however
constantine tells him that he made a
mistake in leaving witnesses that had
seen the vampires alive to tell others
about their existence
because there existed a conspiracy that
manifested supernatural incidents all
across
america to increase the belief in
supernatural phenomena but it would be a
while before he would actually explain
why that was really a problem but
following this encounter with the
rosewood vampires swamp thing would
actually accompany constantine
on various missions around the country
each of which bring them in contact with
various occult entities
the last of which was a haunted house in
san miguel california
now after completing this mission which
constantine assured swamp thing would be
the last one before what he called the
big finale he takes swamp thing to the
monitor satellite in space where he
meets many of the dc heroes that are
discussing the impending crisis on
infinite earth now for those of you guys
who may not be familiar
crisis on infinite earth as most of you
guys probably know was a line-wide event
in dc
that was conceived as a way to
streamline dc's continuity they managed
to get alan moore to let what was going
on
in crisis affect what he was writing in
his vertigo swamp thing run which is
surprising because if there's anybody in
comics who would just
ignore a line-wide publishing initiative
you'd think it'd be alan moore but
regardless
swamping is confronted by alex luther jr
who was a central figure in crisis who
helped the dc heroes defeat the
anti-monitor
after the monitor had been killed but
before he did that he meets swan thing
and tells him that he'll be responsible
for dealing with the ramifications of
the spiritual realm that are brought
about by the crisis on infinitives event
and so it's at this point the
constantine tell swamp thing about the
brugeria cult a group of warlocks that
have been operating in south america for
centuries now in addition to revealing
disturbing details such as the
initiation ritual
and the fact that members wear human
skin constantine informed swamping that
the cult has orchestrated the series of
supernatural events the two of them had
been responding to in order to increase
the belief that people have in the
occult because according to them
belief is power their end goal he
explains is to take advantage of the
weakening of the spiritual plane that
the christ on infinite nurse event will
cause to bring about the return of an
entity
capable of destroying heaven now to
combat this mysterious entity swamp
thing travels to the afterlife to enlist
the assistance
of dead man the phantom stranger etrigan
the demon and the specter now we end up
seeing a conversation between cain and
abel which seems a little bit out of
place where kane describes the great
evil beast
as the terrible primordial shadow that's
slept in chaos beyond hell and the soul
of darkness itself and the complete
absence of divine light which gives us a
sense of the immense scope of who we're
dealing with here but as the great evil
beast draws near etrigan amasses an army
of demons who form an uneasy alliance
with an army of angels
being recruited by the phantom stranger
and the heroes are also joined by dr
faith whose vast mystical powers have
clued him in to the coming of this
incredible evil entity and so as the
battle commences
etrigan is absorbed by the great
darkness who demands of etrigon a simple
question
who am i etragen responds by telling
your name is evil
and that he's the absence of light his
shadow partner locked in an endless
fight the beast tells etrigan that this
has taught him fatalism and
inevitability but explains that it's not
the knowledge that he needs
and spits etragon out the darkness then
absorbs dr fate and asks him what evil
is
fate replies that evil is a quagmire of
ignorance that tries to halt man's climb
towards god's light and tells him evil
is vile and wretched from this the beast
learns that he and god cannot respect
each other
and learns the concept of contempt
before spitting dr fate out now as the
beast begins slaughtering the angelic
army that had been assembled the spectre
shows up and enters the darkness
the specter then teaches the darkness
that the purpose of evil is to be
avenged so that others can see the
negative consequences of committing evil
and turn away from it from this
conversation the beast learns the
concept of revenge for the eons of
torture that is endured and then spits
out spectre which is an incredibly
impressive feat in and of itself
right as a specter is literally the
embodiment of god's wrath and one of
dc's
strongest characters now just as it
seems the great evil beast will succeed
in destroying heaven
swamp thing approaches it and enters its
presence the beast asks swamp thing what
the purpose of evil
is and swamp thing recalls a
conversation that he had with the
parliament of trees which led him to
believe
that just as life needs decay to exist
evil is necessary for good to exist
at this swamp thing is allowed to leave
unharmed and the beast reaches towards
heaven
where it's met by the outstretched hand
of god or the presence or whatever you
want to call the supreme deity in dc
comics but the two hands clasp together
and then simply disappear
but constantine assures those gathered
that this was not a victory
it was simply just a draw now something
that i want to point out here is that in
the lucifer series this year
uh dan waters basically threw out the
idea that lucifer was in fact the great
evil beast right the only way we really
know that is because there's a point
where you see all these different
versions of lucifer right and one of
them
is a great big huge hand which is
basically the hand of the great evil
beast and when when he was asked
on twitter if that was the case if
lucifer is basically the great evil
beast the response to dan waters is yes
the problem with this is that it's
largely contested
right like a lot of fans out there are
like no lucifer's not the great evil
beast it's a wholly different entity
it depends on who you're talking to
right so some people consider that to be
the actual thing that it really is
lucifer others say no but regardless of
how you slice it
not much more is known about the great
evil beast what we do know is that it's
the embodiment of evil and darkness in
the dc universe which
lends credence to the idea that it's an
aspect of lucifer and that he's vastly
more powerful than etrigan dr
fate who's the most powerful wielder of
magic in dc and even the spectre who be
defeated with ease in fact this specter
would later be punished by the presence
for failing to stop the beast and heaven
from merging furthermore the combined
forces of some of dc's most powerful
characters were unable to mount any
resistance whatsoever
against the great evil beast and its
destruction was only stopped when it
became locked in an eternal union with
the presence
suggesting that the two of them are
equal in terms of power again
pointing to the idea that the great evil
beast is basically lucifer but yeah
that's pretty much
all there is to know about the great
evil beast right it's a concept that
hasn't really been revisited very often
after its initial appearance probably
because it's simply just too powerful to
be defeated in any believable way and to
bring it back would probably mean the
destruction of the dc universe but let
me know what you guys think right do you
find this character interesting
i'm kind of curious let me know down in
the comments uh but if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you